Okay.
All right. Youtube. We're live.
We're going old school today.
I'm doing something that I've only done
I think one time before an interview via
Google hangouts.
We've only done this once before we did
it right when I moved into this house
when we were building out the
studio and we didn't have a studio.
My first ever interview
with Jordan Peterson,
which was the first time
that I ever talked to Jordan.
We did via Google hangout sitting in
my living room over there yesterday.
I was supposed to have Avi Yemeni who
is in that box right there who I'll
introduce to you in a second.
I was supposed to have him right here in
studio for a normal show and he was on
his way a couple of days ago from
Australia to the United States,
which is a freaking long,
and I took a,
I took a 15 hour flight from a,
I guess it was from Sydney to uh,
to Texas a couple of weeks ago after a
five hour flight I think from Perth to
Sydney or something like that.
I mean it was like 30 something
hours of total travel. Anyway,
it's a long ass flight.
He tried to enter the United
States and he was denied entry.
Now why did it all this happen? While I'm
going to kick it to Abi Right now, Abi,
first off,
before we do anything else here,
for any of my audience that
does not know who you are,
what's the best way to describe you?
Consider yourself a youtuber or you are
provocative tour or your, your sort of,
uh, a quasi 20, 19 journalists.
What do you consider yourself?
I'm actually a journalist,
a freelance journalist.
I work mostly with Dr News.
Um,
I started on a, I wasn't getting sign
up and uh, the guy bought the uh,
Eh tag audit Riley's on
Australian Israeli, uh,
proud of Bo love, the three
western way of life. Um,
I kind of fell into this.
I was,
I was a gym owner that ran Krav Maga
gyms if you know what they are. Yeah.
Optimize Riley army service.
And to be honest,
it was a really,
when one of the operations
in Gaza kind of kicked off,
then I was watching like the mainstream
media report on it and I was getting
started frustrated with their reporting
and I'd really popular gyms at the time.
I just started kind of commenting and
writing what I experienced myself and what
I knew to be true from the ground,
from someone who actually
served on the front line then.
And I guess it kind of
started a conversation.
I lost a lot of members at the time.
I also gained a few, but, uh, um,
I guess after that I kind of found a
voice and I continue kind of commenting on
all sorts of political issues and
people kind of gave me some constructive
criticism. People that are
alive, people that I trust,
so maybe don't use your business page
for that. So I opened a Facebook page,
I just started speaking. And, um,
now youtube is a new
thing for me to be honest,
because before that I was
100% on until they, uh,
they kicked me off and,
uh, apparently hate speech,
which I don't believe I ever engage in,
you know,
but obviously, uh, it's very broad,
those terms. So that's where I am today.
I work mainly put Tommy
Robinson who, uh, is,
he's very well known obviously in the UK.
Yeah. And I think Tommy, we were trying
to get him in here and uh, you know,
I interviewed him once years ago on Skype
and I don't even think he's allowed to
come to the United States either.
So you're,
you're in company with people that can
or can't get into the good old United
States. Okay. So, uh,
I want you to tell exactly what happened
with Jim Jefferies and comedy central.
I should preface this by saying that
until, uh, the clip that I saw of you,
which now has millions and millions,
I think over 3 million views on youtube.
I have never seen Jim Jeffrey show.
I don't really know who he is.
I know he's a comedian, but I don't
really know who he is, so I have no, um,
you know,
dog in this fight one way or another.
It's not like I'm a fan of
his or a hater of his. Um,
I don't really watch comedy central.
I don't think anyone really watches comedy
central anymore. I think pretty much,
pretty much. I, I think, I know the last
time I watch comedy central, um, was when,
uh, when Jon Stewart was
still hosting the daily show.
He had ion Hirsi Ali on and he
threw her under the bus in Wa.
I don't know if you've seen it.
It was one of the most disgusting
interviews I've ever seen. It's really,
really awful. Um, and I pretty much
just tuned out a comedy central than,
and you know, uh, I
think since then, well,
I guess maybe it's
Futurama still on there.
I've no idea. I didn't even watch
it to be honest, to be honest.
Jim Jeffries is an Aussie who,
um,
who got famous in America. It
wasn't, he was kind of crappy.
Yeah. He just, he likes to drop the
C bomb a lot, I guess in America.
You folks go in and find that
fascinating and funny. Um,
well one thing I did,
like I was a fan of these ones because
he wa he would push the boundaries.
He wasn't, he wasn't
politically correct. Um,
he would make jokes about
kind of anything. Uh, but, uh,
I think over the last few
years, especially when it
comes to the gun debate, uh,
he's found he's,
he's a little place in Hollywood.
And even in some of the clips
that I released after that,
or if you watch the whole clip, you can
see, I challenge him on it. I call him,
I'll tell him he's a,
he's a sellout and he admits he
admitted the life in Hollywood is nice.
So you can't really like, I don't
blame him for that part of it. Like I,
I can understand it.
Yeah.
Okay. So, yeah. So before we
get too, too far ahead though,
and I have no doubt that at the Viacom
building in New York City and in La Right
now, there are plenty of executives
watching this. So you can talk,
you can talk directly to them and
you can talk directly to Jim. Uh,
I suspect Jim is not going to retweet
this, although I did tag him in it.
But anyway, I preface it that way just
to say I brought in, you're not blocked.
Yeah, I know. I'm sure
I'll be boxing it up.
But I preface it that way just to
say I have nothing against the guys
specifically until I saw what happened.
And now it's like,
this is just such,
the reason I wanted to have you on was
that it's such a perfect example of fake
news of media manipulation,
the way that these people often these
media personalities privately do one thing
and publicly do another.
I mean it's just,
and then really to your credit that you
were smart enough to videotape the whole
thing.
So just start at the beginning.
How did you even get on the
Jim Jeffrey show? [inaudible]
traditionally did call me
out into is a December time.
I'm always in Israel at the time,
if I remember correctly. Well,
maybe I was in Europe, but it
gave me a call and said, listen,
Jim is the traveling Australia
at the moment. He's uh,
he's organizing,
he's doing a tour in Australia,
but he was running a special
for a Netflix or one of them,
one of these comedy central
specials. Um, and he was wondering,
you probably would be willing to
come on to discuss immigration,
to discuss the border wall.
And I,
I know who Jim Jeffries is and I know
where he stands or at least publicly where
he stands these days on
issues. And I'm not, I'm like,
I'm somebody that's confident in my
beliefs. I have no problem, you know,
discussing anything with anyone.
But I also know he's on trustworthy and
I've been involved in the media for long
enough to know that I need to set out
some conditions and I set out to basic
conditions.
One,
don't put me with neo Nazis or anyone who
believes he had learned he wouldn't do.
And two is just put my answers to
the questions that you asked me.
Don't cut it up. And with a technique
that they love doing. And you know, I,
I do a lot of street interviews myself
and I would never do that to somebody
because there's no point.
The whole idea is if somebody is
stupid or if somebody answers something
ridiculous ridiculously, you
don't need to cut it. Yeah.
You can actually just put
it out there and everybody,
the world is there to judge.
Yeah. But that's kind of the game these
guys have been playing for a long time.
Right.
Like I interned,
I interned at the daily show back in
1999 it's a long freaking time ago and I
remember, you know, I don't know that
they were doing what he did with you,
which is taking an answer to one
question in placing it to another.
But I always remember thinking when
they'd get these local Republicans on and
then mock them the whole time, it's like,
what, what were these idiots thinking?
Like, you know, you're
walking into the daily show,
like you know you're going
to be selectively edited
or they're going to put a
pause on you in a weird way
for a laugh or, or just some,
some level of manipulation.
So you went out your way.
Just don't expect it to be
so bad like it to be honest.
The last one I'd seen of Jim Jefferies,
he's what he did to Jordan Peterson
and I thought to myself, you know,
I look at someone like Jordan,
Jordan Peterson,
and I look at him and he's an academic.
He's far smarter than me
and if Jim Jefferies could
make him kind of look like a
dumb ass,
then obviously he's out to get me.
So they agree to those terms.
And I went to,
they flew me to Singapore.
I,
I told him that the third issue is that
I'm just not in Australia at the moment,
so I'm happy to do it. If you, if
you agree to those two conditions,
I'm happy to do it. But obviously
it has to be the term that I can,
it worked at that,
that flew me to Singapore.
Pay For my hotel and paid all my expenses.
It was great little trip.
I walk in there and I knew, I also
spoke to my good friend Tommy Robinson,
who's had a lot of experience with fake
news and great straightaway. He said,
make sure you've got footage on it.
So I went in there and I
thought I had two phones.
I don't want them to phones.
I went in there because I wanted
to make sure in case one collapse,
which it actually did.
That's why if you look at the footage,
some of it's blurry because the very one
actually recorded the whole thing and I
walk in and I was thinking if they stop
me and I started recording from the
moment I walked in because
I said if they stopped me,
I didn't care at that point.
If they kicked me out while I'm
setting up my cameras to film myself,
then that's not video show that they're
not even willing to engage me without
trying to screw me. But nobody noticed,
nobody noticed anything and I set it up.
It was like it was couches and
I put these pillows. There was,
it took me a good minute and I went
even went back and reset it. It was,
that was so self absorbed
on their,
on their egos or their importance
or something. Absolutely.
And I just filmed the whole thing.
It was,
it was a couple of months I think
too. I just held onto it. I didn't,
I could've put that Mohammed stuff
out straight away, but I thought,
you know what, I'm going to wait.
I want to see how this plays out.
And I was actually at a Purim event,
so what is it, a couple of weeks ago,
and I didn't even know the,
the segment at Baym released and some,
you know Habad rabbi walks
up to me, he goes, Oh,
I saw your Jim Jefferies thing last night.
They totally,
he screwed you or he, I think his
wording was more like he wrecked you.
Lucky it was as if he even,
he believed the context of the,
of the interview and that all
the cuts were actually true.
I'm sitting there like after a
few, you know, poor him drinks,
I'm just open up my phone and
I'm just watching. And I'm going,
I can't believe this.
He's literally put me in the context
of Christ's Church of the Cross church
massacre with some crazy
white supremacists who hate
my guts a hundred percent.
He believes that you should be in Israel.
He doesn't think of
Israeli is a good thing.
Just to be very clear, you taped
the interview, what a good two,
three months before.
And I'm looking at it and I'm in shock.
I'm saying that cut up.
My aunt is in 20 seconds of the clip.
They have the most prominent
neo Nazi in Australia. Um, they,
they've, uh, cut up even
not even just my aunties,
even my facial reaction,
my expressions,
I took expressions when he would
say something bizarre and I would,
I would like cringe up my face. He,
he's taken that and cut it with,
you know,
reasonable questions that he's asked
and he's even saying the best part was I
got him saying he will, um, he can cut
it up to make himself look perfect. So I,
I honestly, I went home and, and,
and I just myself, I went and I said,
I told her how bad guy there, the
rabbi, I said, wait till tomorrow,
you'll see you'll see the tree.
Then I went back and now what's odd to
me is I expected that once they see that
that will will retract
immediately that you apologize,
they will remove the defamatory content.
No,
they didn't do any of that and they
still haven't done any of that. In fact,
I managed to get banned on Youtube.
It picked him up.
I managed to get band within 24
hours from posting that on Facebook.
Facebook denies it has
anything to do with that,
but they won't give me any proof on
any other posts. Um, that has, uh,
that, that bridge their terms
and conditions. In fact,
I didn't post anything for a good period
besides for the Jim Jeffrey stuff.
So I don't know what it possibly
can be. Um, okay. So for the,
for the people that haven't seen it,
so he splices answers that you give to
other questions to make it seem like
you're, you're racist basically. I'm
a radical, I'm crazy. And the fact is,
if I watched that, if I watched
that, I don't like that guy. Oh,
that guy.
And that was what it was designed to
do was to make me look like a bad job,
you know? And he tried to, he tried to
make it like he literally says, Gee,
the only thing that could bring Jews
and white supremacists together is there
shared height from was
absolutely outrageous.
Disgusting. The fact is, I don't,
I've never shown hate from Muslims ever
in my life because I think hating on a
people is wrong. As a Jew, I find
that offensive to hate on us,
to target a people to criticize Islam.
I always do it because I think
any idea should be tested,
tried and tested and discuss.
But um,
it wasn't just though that
he manipulated what you said,
what you also caught him saying
off camera and this really to me,
this is the beauty of it because I think
even if beforehand you said to them,
guys, don't sandbagged me,
you know, don't edit my stuff.
And they promised to do all
that. Like, I live in Hollywood,
I know how this business works.
They're all liars and frauds and
they'll say anything and do any of that.
The real,
the real meat of this is what you caught
him saying because that really shows
the one 80 on reality. So could
you lay out some of that is, look,
Jim Jefferies used to say a lot of that
stuff publicly in a lot of his original
shows, um, lightly. Obviously he's, uh,
he's become a very good liberal
lovie dovie. It's all about, uh,
you know,
and the thing is that segment,
that specific segment was about pointing
at people like me and blaming us for
radicalizing people like that
crazy Christchurch killer. Um,
he's gone in there, he's drawn
Mohammad, you know, he's um,
he even went as far as making it,
he made a few jokes and said how much
you hate Islamic fallen. Fair enough.
I actually have no
problem with what he said.
And especially in the context of comedy,
I think it's fine.
I just don't think you have the right
then to turn around and point fingers at
someone like me. You would never even
say anything close to what he said.
Even as a joke.
In fact,
I had to pull him up at one point where
he was joking about dingoes killing
little Muslim babies and vomiting,
which is just not even funny.
And now for those who are out there who
were claiming that he only said it to
bait me,
well no actually originally he used to,
he used to be like that.
He used to say that publicly is changed
because now that's where you know he's
following the money. He obviously
doesn't believe anything he preaches.
He's two faced is exactly the
definition of two faced and fake.
But also if he was trying to beat you to
do the baiting off camera and then your
answers aren't coming. I mean
that in and of itself, again,
this is not surprising
how these guys operate,
but that would show you a little
bit of the motivations there.
Absolutely it,
he came in with certain intentions
and the thing is he couldn't,
he didn't get the outcome he wanted.
So the only way to produce it was
literally to reproduce it, to cut it up.
And anyone can look stupid when you do
that and anyone can look bad and you can
literally ruin someone's life.
If I didn't capture that,
my life would be ruined.
There's no way for me to be able to
defend against any of what he's put out
there.
I still find it crazy that till
today they've not only not responded,
they blocked and banned any,
you know a lot of people and you can look,
you know, some people aren't getting
banned, you or may so far not.
But if you look at my Twitter,
there's posts up that I keep
re tweeting of people just bad.
And for what they're saying is literally,
can you at least faced what you've done?
Jim Can,
can comedy central make a statement?
Can you do something? But nothing,
they just blocking their vaccine
restricted comments on Instagram.
So that's what I think is so interesting
here because it's such a perfect storm
of all of the crap that I'm always
talking about. Hearing what's wrong,
the media and then,
and then how people,
individuals online are able to fight back.
Because right now if you look at comedy
central's a Twitter feed or the Jim
Jeffrey show,
typically if you look at your mentions,
it is no matter what he tweets,
it's real people,
decent human beings saying, are you
going to address this and all that.
So before we get to what happened when
you tried to get to the United States to
be in the studio yesterday, um, if,
if comedy central today or Jim
Jefferies personally issued an apology,
admitted the whole thing, which app,
which now everyone knows to be true.
So it's not much of a mia
culpa because it's like, yeah,
you're just admitting
what blatantly is obvious.
Would you accept that and then
just move on from this situation?
Well,
what we'll everyday that passes,
the bigger the apology is going
to have to be, the more, the more,
the louder it's going to have
to be because it now on their,
all their social media platforms, that
defamatory video has been up, what is it,
two weeks now? Um, they'd
been running it on cable TV.
It's been everywhere.
So you,
they've kind of got to reach everyone
reached to in and out. Having said that,
I think my video has
reached more than this,
but I don't know if
it's the same audience.
They need to really show that they finally
accept what they did and that it was
wrong and it is not, you know, I've heard
a lot of people turn around and go, oh,
but how can you type comedy
central series after all,
it's called comedy central,
but I don't accept that because one,
it wasn't a joke what
they were discussing.
It wasn't a joke the time
that they were discussing,
it wasn't a joke that
they were pointing at me.
For someone who was partly
responsible in making that happen,
it's not a joke to cut somebody up.
I don't mind.
I make fun of myself all day every
day. If you watch my youtube, I like,
I have no problem doing that.
But there were certain
lines that even I like,
I don't get offended easily,
but I am freaking offended by the
content that they produce. So yes,
in theory it would accept an apology
and then taking responsibility.
But it has to match the amount.
They pushed the fight news till now.
Yeah. And I don't even know how they
could do that at this point. I mean I,
you know, it's so interesting also because
that's why I decided to do a long form
interview show in the first place
years ago. Cause I was like,
I'll do these things. We won't edit
for content. I liked doing them live.
You can say whatever you want.
I can edit you.
And ironically when I do I'll get
10 his camera off man. I know.
Yeah, exactly what? Like
when I, when I do television,
it's so funny because Fox News is
the only one that'll put me on.
I was on Tucker last night, but it's live.
There's no chance that they're getting,
they could sandbag me, you know, ask me
something intentionally inflammatory.
It's all live and absolutely. I know, I
just wouldn't go on the shows anymore.
That wouldn't be a problem. I know people
were criticizing me for going. Why,
why would you even, why would you
even do it? Well, there's two things.
One is I knew I was going to record it,
so it was a win win.
I was going to either get a good
segment where I actually got to, uh,
reach an audience that I
wouldn't typically be able
to reach and have my say and
present my opinions, um, and maybe
change a few minds, maybe not,
whatever,
um,
but at least be presented properly or
I'm going to get to expose the fake news.
And that's exactly what I did.
And I'm gonna call on fake
news even though they are
comedy central because that
is what they did. And people come to
those shows to get the newsies. It's sad.
It is sad.
But people come to those shows to get
their news and the fact is if they
presented as real news than it is just
the same meetings all the time and they
have that platform that I
have that responsibility.
Yeah. Well I, I completely agree with
that because you know, remember when,
when Jon Stewart was hosting
the daily show, I mean,
I know no one watches it anymore.
It's completely irrelevant. But when,
when Stewart was hosting the daily
show and Obama was president,
the meme out there on
all of mainstream media,
every article that was written about
daily show was more young people get their
news from the daily show.
Then from CNN, New York Times
to have it both ways.
But it's true. Like even here in
Australia, we have a, I don't know,
I don't know if you were
experienced in the project.
I don't know if Jordan was he,
when you guys were here on the project,
the project is assigned knees.
It's meant to be, you know,
a lot harder to comment and it does
reach the younger people and it's,
it's just not funny to take people
out of context to ruin people's lives.
It's wrong.
Okay, so now you get on a plane,
you, so the video goes viral.
Everybody seeing this, you're getting,
you're getting retweeted I think by,
by all the people that I know really
try to push back against this.
This means media nonsense. And you know,
I, I didn't know who you were before.
So I watched it and I was like, all right,
this, this is legit. Like I'm watching.
I didn't know.
I didn't know you're going to make
hurtful statements in this interview.
And you didn't know him, even
from Jay's says, Hey, I know
you now. I know, you know,
you know. Um, but you know, I'd
seen this game before, so I was,
I was more than happy to just spread
awareness about this. Okay. Yep.
So then you reach out
and you say, uh, well,
I think maybe I reached out to
you first. And I said, you know,
if you want to come in studio,
let, let's make this happen. Yeah.
Within a day you were like, all right,
I'm coming to the states. Uh, so what,
say it was
actually, it was you that, uh,
that, that inspired me to come.
Um, when, when you said, when we
had, we started the conversation,
I can't remember exactly how it
started, but, um, I said, you know what?
And I spoke to Sydney Watson, who's a
good friend here, who is very publisher,
you know, she's a Sky News
contributor. She has her own uh,
following and she was like, yeah, let's
do it. She's hot. She's a jewel citizen,
American, Australian. And we said,
let's do this. Let's go, you know,
we already had sapling. We have something
in place. We're going to go Reuben,
and then we're going to go, you know,
my idea was to go to comedy central,
just walk in the door,
you know,
talk to somebody with the comedy
central logo on a moment. You know,
anyone can watch any of my content.
I, when I'm asked to leave, I leave.
But that, that, that's good enough for me.
I'll walk into comedy central and if I
bring up some content that you've got and
you asked me to leave, that's
telling, that's enough visual.
Let somebody come in the central ledger,
you know,
right now that's been my problem
is no one even wants to respond.
The same producer that was so open to
talking to me before is not responding to
my whatsapp messages anymore.
That's it.
What's,
what's so interesting to me,
it's like they don't even understand
the Internet game that they think that
they're a part of.
Like they think that if you just ignore
this long enough that it's going to go
away. But I mean they're,
they're messing with the wrong.
I can't, I keep telling me there's
two people they need to talk to.
I can talk to my mom,
ask her how persistent on am I'm a pain
in her eyes to speak to my officer in
the army.
Like I flew halfway around the world
just to join the IDF to be on the front
line in a specific unit.
And I got there,
I'm going to go till they respond
and they, they need to know that. Um,
so we decided to do this, we call it
the American tour against fake news.
We're going to come to you on your show.
A few other shows that are organized. Um,
and it was just growing. It was you
in the beginning. And we just don't,
we're built around that. Well,
I was going to go do his, uh,
Jim Jefferies show in Maryland,
see if I can actually engage him.
Oh Man. Um, and I was
going to talk to just,
even the people lining up in the audience.
Now I want to make it
clear I was going to do it.
I'm not in a threatening manner on tiny,
like I'm, I'm, I'm a little guy.
I'd never end and you can say are going
to supplies in the, you know, online.
You see that brand is a lot
bigger than me. Generally,
I'm the smallest guy in the room.
I'm not very threatening and I'm willing
to talk to anybody and only talk.
I only ever talk. So there's
no basis for any, um,
perceived real threat. But, uh,
when we got to the states,
it was myself and Sydney.
Sydney's even Sydney is bigger than me,
but it'd be a tall girl and we
get there and they've, Abi, you,
she's with her. She's got an American
thing, was always split up straight away.
Um,
I've gone into the line now,
as soon as I've come to the, uh,
to the immigration desk, the,
something's obviously
popped up on your screen.
As soon as he's a swat my
passport and he goes, are,
you just need to come with me. We need
to update some details about your, uh,
about your,
I think it's called STV,
like the visa waiver program that
we had here with Australia. So I'm,
I'm fine at this point. I still think
it's okay. The acting quite normal.
Take me to a back room.
His superior officer is there and I
found that interesting because he kind of
seemed like he knew my name
already and he was expecting me,
but I went with the flow and taking me
around and lax to an area where it's more
secluded. Put your bags on a thing.
He's been going through my bag,
checking if I've got over $10,000, I'll
wish I did. Not, nothing close to it.
Um,
they're asking me more questions about
what I'm doing here and it's all still,
um, reasonable. I'm starting to
get a little bit more suspicious.
They've written down a bunch of stuff
and then I got, okay, we just got,
we've got a few more questions.
We'll go sit in this room and
talk because I knew it's on,
that opened the door to this back
room. There's two FBI agents, you know,
there's one man in a suit and then
a woman behind a computer and a,
they shined. Their idea
got everywhere. I looked,
I saw that and I just cracked up laughing.
I looked at him and I'll just
go to comedy central and the,
the,
the agent tends to be guys,
we are actually a separate
entity to comedy central.
Blackie had to say that like he had
to tell me now. And um, I've got,
I've said, I've responded going, we'll uh,
but comedy central is the informant.
Yeah.
And he just responded straight away.
And this is when people ask me,
how do you not comedy says, well,
he's gone. He said to me, literally,
we've received a number of complaints
from comedy central about certain things
that we just want to clarify.
Okay.
So we got to really drill this one home.
That means that comedy central contacted
either the FBI or the Tsa or whatever
else is going on there. The three
I's, what are and as hell man,
maybe that called law enforcement who
decided it's in the jurisdiction of FBI
because they knew that you were
coming to the United States,
I guess to do a couple of
shows including this one.
And you are going to just talk.
I know, I don't know if you saw my
description on the, it was on my website,
the description of what we were doing
there. So we're coming on your show.
We're going on Steven Crowder. We're
going to move, we're going to go confront.
Exactly.
So they've called and they
literally given screenshots.
I've taken screenshots of different posts
I've made, including one from Eylea,
a British, uh, Eh, uh, conservative,
the news site,
which,
how did I use an image of me
as an IDF soldier with my,
uh,
with my rifle.
And they've basically taken everything
and gone through it as in are they 20?
Am I trying to obtain
weapons? I turned him, I go,
the only weapons I have that I need in
this tool is my microphone and my camera.
That's all. And look, by the end
of it, the FBI had cleared me,
the FBI were laughing with me about it.
They actually said to me,
I understand why you want to come and
clear your name. Yeah, that's fine.
They got they, they got it.
They were actually really nice.
Like I have no problem with them. I
have no problem with that. With the uh,
the border protection either.
My problem here is that comedy central
who have been ignoring all these had the
time to go to the FBI.
You know,
they've gone out of their way to just
silence at first online when all these
people are uh, you know, responding back,
asking him just to make a statement.
They blocking people by the
hundreds and then on top of that,
when they hear them coming to the states,
they literally contacted the FBI to try
get them to stop me from coming on the,
on the premise that I am coming
there to violently assault somebody.
Okay.
So going on the assumption you we're
not here to violently assaulted and that
the FBI was on board that and that
they accepted what you were laying out,
that you were just here to do
interviews and that sort of thing.
Obviously all true and Co and
the fact that comedy central,
I mean it really like,
it shows some other layer
of really perverse collusion
between networks and the
FBI. I mean, how insane is
that? But they did catch you on,
on a technicality related from years ago.
So it's important.
I think it's important to talk about.
Otherwise people are going to think, Whoa,
the FBI's in on some real conspiracy.
Right?
So once that happened,
it obviously triggered whatever
process, the, uh, border protection hat,
which is to go through
everything within your visa,
visa or visa waiver, whatever it is that
you're coming in on. And what they found,
we had a few, you know, it was over.
The interrogation with the
FBI was for about an hour.
Then there was a couple of other,
you know,
interviews with the different
border protection, um,
with the highest levels in lax.
And actually I'm not going to,
boy won't hurt their, their jobs, but
they were actually really good papers.
I have no problem with them.
And I believe in border protection
and if somebody makes a mistake,
like what I found.
So what it turned out is two years
ago when I filled out this visa waiver
application on online,
which I want to point out,
I had come even seven months
ago, the New York, um, I was, I,
I'd been in the states, only sign
these up from that same application.
So there was no problem and it
was an absolute technicality.
So what they found is when you fill
out these visa waiver forms online,
there's a bunch of crazy questions
and you know, you just like, um,
I rate him out. No, no, no, I'm
not a terrorist. I'm not this,
I'm not a neo Nazi or not there to create
balance. I've never been to just do, no,
no, no, no. One of them
happened to say, um,
have you ever been
denied a visa to the US?
Now is about 15 years ago.
Um,
I came on a visa waiver and right
after I got back to Australia,
I applied for a visa.
They thought that implied that I
was trying to come there to live.
So I was trying to immigrate to the
u s and I got denied a visa. Now,
I don't know, I don't even remember
filling in the phone, so I don't know.
But that happened. Um, and I said
that openly to the uh, the, uh,
the border protection officer.
That technicality means that it makes the,
the application void and now it
means, so that was saying to me, look,
you're not getting banned. There's nothing
wrong. It's an accident. In fact, they,
they said to me, if we, um,
basically investigate the same way
we did your scrutinize, every app,
every person that comes
here on a visa waiver,
probably half of them will end up
doing a mistake on that upper gudgeon.
There'll be thrown out as well.
Or are you going to do is go back
to Australia and apply for a visa?
He can't use the visa
waiver program anymore.
You've got to actually have a
visa because you have been denied.
Now just to remember that
this is a technicality on a
technicality because irony
got refused the visa back then
because I was trying to immigrate.
Well in their minds it was the risk that
I was trying to immigrate to the US.
Now obviously when I was
there seven months ago,
I didn't immigrate to the u
s so even that was wrong. Um,
but I accept that this, listen, I have
no, I have no problem with that. I'm here.
I'm going to reapply and
everything you're saying is true.
I'm going to get in because I
have no criminal record. I'm not,
there's no reason for me
not to get the visa. Um,
my problem with it all is that
practically on a practical level,
comedy central got me kicked out even in
the short term. Even in the short term,
they managed to get me kicked out because
the fact that they were able to go to
the FBI and complain,
they triggered this investigation.
They got me out on a technicality
that in their own words, most people,
or at least half the people that come
into the US would, um, would file as well.
Right.
So the point here is,
the point here is that seven months
ago you got in with no problem and that
comedy central then triggers this by
contacting the FBI shows that they have
some level of power even if the agents
are going, yeah, this is nonsense.
It was 15 years ago. And everyone
knows when you're, when you're going,
you know when you're landing in another
country or you're filling out these
things,
sometimes they're written
in very confusing ways where
you almost think know me.
Yeah.
Um, I'm not even going to take that
experience cause I've got a nice shirt.
They printed it out for me.
It was very clean.
But there are so many questions
that most of them are crazy.
So you just kind of do, no, no,
no, no, no, no. In the time,
I wouldn't have lied about
it for nothing because I,
I would have thought if I'd seen that
one that obviously they'll know if about
being denied or not. It's
there. It's their immigration.
I can't believe that in pick
it up automatically. Yeah. Yes.
So that's exactly what's happened.
So have you, um, you know,
this is a weird thing that I think the
free speech crew is now confronted with
where,
you know,
when we're the ones that are getting
liable than slandered all the time and
having reputations destroyed and
having a media manipulated and,
and video editing and all of these things,
uh,
it's a weird place for us to be the ones
having to talk about legal remedies.
But have you thought about this at all?
We are at the moment,
yes.
We've got a few things down on
and a that we're working with.
We're going to pop these
from a few friends.
Then my main objective more than anything
is to get them to face up to what
they've done and to respond
and take responsibility
over it because it is wrong.
I don't care if you're from the left,
if you from the right,
I don't care to do that,
to do what they've done.
And further to add insult to injury to
at every point that you have a chance to
stand up and take that responsibility.
Take and,
and apologize not only to me
apologize to your, to your fans.
I've seen so many people on Jim Jeffrey,
things that have actually said,
I don't even like avi,
I'm even like what he stands for.
I don't agree with anything,
but what you did is wrong.
At least give those, you know,
do the right thing. And you know,
when I was in the airport at the time,
I was there always the
time for about 15 hours.
And the hardest part
for me in that time is,
besides being treated like a criminal,
was the fact that it Sydney walks
and we're sitting in, in the airport,
lost in, you know, waiting for,
we had a flat together to New York
that she just sitting there not knowing
what's going on. I kept asking a border
protection if they were informing her.
They said, yes, I've got one phone
call. In fact, they were good.
I actually got me two phone calls and,
and, and he let me tweet and you said,
don't tweet anything about me brother.
Uh, but that, that, that will,
that will nicely. But the fact is that,
you know, I was sitting there going,
is she all right? You know,
it's a, it's a foreign country.
Might have American citizenship,
but she's an Ozzie put friends from he
here and we went into trouble together.
We're not creamy. I'm suddenly being,
the time she got questioned as well.
She was also investigated, but they
couldn't do anything. She's American.
Um, so it was for her, since
I've seen on her, you know,
I didn't even really know everything.
She went through tool.
I watched her youtube summary of what Ha,
what she gone through on that day.
And it's,
it's horrible and it's painful for me to
watch it because it's all comes down to
comedy central doing literally
trying to silence us.
What's also crazy to me is the,
the way that they don't know
how this game will play out.
It's like if they would've done,
well first I'm doing the right thing,
would've been not selectively editing,
but okay, let's say they can't,
they can't do it that way cause
they're playing a certain game.
Well then once you call them out on
it, you just immediately, you know,
we messed this one up,
especially after the Christchurch thing
where we're emotions were so high.
It's coming off a horrific,
horrific,
horrific tragedy that you had
taped this thing way before.
I mean there was a way they could
have gotten out. You know, we just,
we just botched this one.
That's it.
But now they've got it to the point and
that's why I wanted to do this with you.
Where are the longer they let this stew?
It's not just that at this point,
you know, in a way, Jim Jeffrey
should be fired or at least his,
and I don't like calling for this kind
of stuff. This is so not how I do this,
but it's like his executive producer or
whoever made those decisions should be
fired.
But the longer they go on,
you're getting this to the place
where you're gonna have to take out.
Major executives are going to have to
be fired because somebody is now making
these decisions and the way
these corporations work,
it's going to be pretty obvious
through emails and meetings.
Who made the decisions to
to throw you under the bus?
Who made the decision to contact
the FBI and I'm looking up,
we're going to get there.
We're going to get to
the bottom of all that.
We are going to point out at the end of
it, because I am persistent. Like I say,
what's bothering me is that the mainstream
media are not talking about and that
he's obviously,
like I said to you before we came on
is that I believe they think it's a
nonsteroidal.
They're scared to report on it because
suddenly the camera's going to be on them
because they all do it. And that's
why so important. I've been like,
I feel grateful that people like you
and there's been a few of them, phew.
You know, alternative online media,
people who actually have integrity,
who have reported on it. And they're
as outraged about it as I am. Look,
I'm watching it from the slide,
like not even in my,
if I just saw that from the side,
I would be disgusted because
it is so wrong. And I like,
even if it was somebody I
absolutely disagree with,
I would be in his room.
Well that's what I was saying
to you before. It's like,
it's the perfect storm of craziness.
It's media manipulation.
It's leftist insanity.
It's dishonest hosts.
It's all of these things at
once. Do you remember, uh,
about two months ago a alley Stucky who
was actually on my show last week who's
a conservative,
a podcast here.
She did a fake interview with,
uh,
Alexandria ocozzio Cortez where they
just sliced alleys, questions with,
you know, uh, I say shipping here.
I did one lot that is similar and it's
like Allie posted and it was so obvious
that it was fake and it was so obvious
that this is exactly what comedy central
does all the time. And this is
exactly what comes, you know,
daily show and all these
things do all have.
But the media went bananas that it
was the Conservatives spreading a fake
interview to make AOC look ridiculous.
And it's like,
you guys do this to people on the right
every single day that your number one
motivation. I think that's
pretty much the only person.
You don't need a cut in meeting up to me.
Yeah,
exactly. She's doing a,
she's doing a fine job. Yeah,
I don't have it. And they're all
hypocrites. And look, I have,
I'm telling you,
I'll watch it.
I actually thought within a day there
would be mainstream media and there's been
a couple that are going to
Australia. There's a, uh,
a for the Daily Telegraph
and man called Tim Blake.
He's written a few times about it, but
you know, channel 10 years in Australia.
They,
they only wrote it in the
context of bum me being
deported. In fact, it was,
it was disgusting story at first.
Then I called her out on Twitter and
within two minutes she called me back and
you know, she, she in her
report, she actually wrote,
we reached out to RB for comment
with no response and it was like, um,
I was in the tension. How the hell
did you want me to respond? You know,
they're just so full of it.
Everything they do, they,
this is one of the
hallmarks of what they do.
I've had this happened to me many times.
They'll,
they'll reach out for you to comment
about a half hour before the article goes
up. You can be at the freaking
dentist, you could be walking your dog.
But in our own, in our own report, she
was reporting that I was in detention.
How dumb do you think everyone is?
They think people are pretty
dumb and I hate to tell you,
but I can already predict
what's going to happen here.
There'll be a couple of weeks, there'll
be a couple of hit pieces about this.
You'll be said, oh, they put you
on all right, Ruben show. And, uh,
but I mean the Jewish non
Jewish Nazi in Australia.
So I think you might be the one in
for approval. That's fine. Listen,
I've, I've taken the, uh,
what do you think this says about the
way this nonsense is spreading across
borders? Because, uh,
you know, as you know,
I was on tour with Peterson for the last
year and we went to a ton of countries,
including about 10 stops.
And the Australian shows were
absolutely phenomenal. I mean,
just the audiences were incredible.
I just love you guys.
Well, there was just such
a zest for life and fun.
I went out with audience members almost
every night after the show. I just,
I seriously just had a, had
an absolute blast. Um, but,
but what I'm amazed by right now,
after the last year is that I've seen
the way the world operates online and on
Twitter and on Youtube.
But then I've traveled the world and I've
been to Sweden and to Denmark and you
know, Canada and us and, and all
and Ireland and all over the place.
And the fact that there are people in
all of these places that are, you know,
thousands of miles away from each
other thinking the same exact things.
It's pretty powerful.
And I think,
I think that right there is what these
guys fear more than anything else.
That there actually is a worldwide
push back against their nonsense.
Are you feeling that?
Absolutely.
And that's why they're shutting people
down or they're trying to, you see, um,
you know, personally I've been shot off
Facebook for things that they can't even,
they can't even back at they,
you ask them for any evidence and they
can't show you what it is exactly.
And that's the way that they are trying
to solve once you all these different
organizations in the fact that the fact
again that that within 24 hours a month,
my video with my whole page,
which again shows me that
there is a collision there
between comedy central and,
and that's not some crazy conspiracy
theory that that is just common sense
though isn't easy. Um, dots to connect
day. Yeah. Yeah. What do you think?
Why do you think youtube left the video
up? If a, if Facebook took it down,
cause I'm sure we'll
try it on youtube too.
I Dunno. Maybe it's earning
of money. I don't know. I
don't know. I don't know why,
but you know, Youtube I've found over
the last year has been better. Um,
then Facebook or they, you know, until
they get pressured. W for example,
my good friend Tommy Robinson,
they proved his page on Facebook.
Youtube actually defended keeping his
channel up until a number of labor mps
really bullied Facebook into, into, they
will, they didn't want to backtrack.
They defended this, this, as I said, he
never breached their terms and conditions.
So,
um,
then they backtrack once there
was about two months of lobbying,
I'll call it bullying,
bullying by Labor MPs in the UK.
And then suddenly they didn't want to
say that Berlin. So they restricted,
heavily restricted his
channel. Um, youtube, I don't,
I think unless there is some
political been done so far, they see,
I think they're starting to
recognize that, um, you're gonna,
you're running your
business into the ground.
Facebook is running their business into
the ground and you can see it even just
in a shed, but it is a dying
thing. We've all gone to telegram.
We've gone to a lucky basically the
whatsapp that's protected not by Facebook
but by a Russian to Russian brothers
and we're finding it fantastic.
You know the, the, you get the
response, you so much ready,
you see the click throughs.
It is absolutely unbelievable,
but it is crazy that we're being forced
to the other platforms that are meant to
be messaging apps instead of using actual
social media because these different
organizations in different
institutions have hold so much power.
Yeah. Wait, did you mean that you're,
you're actually spreading your videos
through telegram? I mean I know,
I know it's a messaging APP,
but you're saying you're building
an actual audience there.
I didn't even know that was a great
got, we've got, we've got a
group, Tommy, Tommy Robinson use,
we call it Tommy Robinson news and your
members join like any page and you can,
you can even embed likes and things
that people can actually interact.
It's a one way wall and you can link out,
you can do it.
It's so much better than,
so you can put,
we can literally upload
videos there and say, okay,
they're not letting us
put videos on Facebook,
but we'll upload it here with
a little download button.
We don't need our one page.
You guys all have your own pages.
You go upload and flood their,
their um,
different platforms with these content
and it is so much more effective and I
think that that is going to be
the future, to be honest. It is.
That is the future of social media.
If they continue down this park,
all of them are going to crash from
the Twitter, youtube, Facebook,
they're all going to crash unless they
allow people to actually have a fake gun.
Is the perverse part of this? I
always say that it's, you know,
if they would just not
be totally horrible,
we would all have nothing to talk about.
It's like if they were 30%
horrible or like 50% horrible,
we'd kind of complain every now and
again and people would be like, ah,
they're always complaining.
But then they do these sorts of things.
It's like you guys are, it's not that
you're just going all the way horrible.
It's not just that you selectively edit
and you manipulate and you throw people
under the bus and you try to just
spread this chill effect so that,
cause it's not about destroying you.
Right. It's like they know, well,
if we can destroy a hobby,
it's like we can take out thousands of
other people that will never speak up
again. And it's like, man,
if you guys would just not
be all in on the bullshit,
then we'd probably have other
things to be talking about.
Yeah,
look it.
It absolutely is that the fact is I
think they thought I was an easy target.
They'll probably be like you. They
didn't really know who I was. Um,
they just knew,
you know,
if you look in Australia on probably
the biggest name for alternative media
here, none. That's not because
I'm that great. You know,
I think I am just that we don't have
a big alternative media thing here.
So I think they, they, they
thought I'd be an easy target.
And I totally underestimated the practice.
I am not an idiot.
And you know that,
that today to fight back, he's not that
hard because I think science needs to be,
boy is actually,
I think people are looking for the truth.
It's kind of the Trump effect and the
whole idea of fake news, you know, they,
they said Trump,
it's so nuts and he keeps going on about
fake news and it's like they literally
create fake news that is actually a thing.
And anyone that's had anything to do
with media will know that fake news is a
real problem.
And that's not to say Trump is the best
guy in the world or on the most innocent
person in the world.
I've done my fair share of things.
But the fact is that these in
these organizations are corrupt,
so corrupt, and they act like
they are so much better than us.
They hold the moral high ground when
they are the biggest scam in the world.
They are literally worse than
the worst people. You know,
it's so strange.
Guy tweeted something the other day about,
it's like Trump for his orange skin
and his hair plugs and the crazy way he
speaks.
It's like somehow despite all of that,
he's more authentic than them. I mean
that tells it right there. It's right.
Like this guy looks fake.
He doesn't look like a what a what
a regular human being looks like.
Like that's how fake he looks and
the way he speaks the whole thing.
And yet he can actually come off more
authentic than these people because
they're so polished and they got away
with it for so long they don't even know
how to, how to do it right
anymore. I think it's the, yeah,
I imagine on the Internet
where, you know, look for that.
When we saw something on TV, it
was polished. It was perfect,
and that's what we got.
You know,
if we seen something that was a little
bit unpolished, it was kind of odd.
That's rubbish. That's fine. Now we're in
an age where, you know, Google hangouts,
you can do a conversation
from across the world.
Even if they deport someone and you
know, it's the content. It's the words,
it's the, it's the substance.
People are listening to, um,
that nobody cares what Trump looks like.
Nobody cares.
Even though he's rough around the edges
and he's not that articulate and either
nobody cared because people are like,
what's he saying? What's he telling me?
What's he depending? What's he
standing up for? What is Danny against?
And I think that's what shines really.
Like I'll personally, I see it in myself,
I'll look at him and I go, I
like that. And it's just a bonus.
He triggers the people I don't like a lot.
Just so I have an idea here because
there's no doubt that there are dozens.
I have no doubt,
dozens of comedy central employees
and executives watching this right now
sitting in their cubicles
with their headphones,
cause they don't want anyone
to know that they're watching.
But what I find is that over
the course of this show,
I have found people over the years,
James Damore, Lindsay Shepherd,
Bret Weinstein, people who have, you
know, taken unpopular positions or,
or basically stood up to the mob,
I would say more than anything else.
And they've survived. And you're
obviously going to survive this,
so why don't you talk directly to the
comedy central employees right now,
the executives who are going to have to
make some decisions on that are we are,
we are, we got about eight minutes left.
I mean, let's tell them what to do.
We got it that you want the
apology, but, but if they're there,
if they're in the belly of the beast,
what do you think they should do?
Good. Hi Guys, my name's Avi.
Can you probably recognize me from the
last two weeks of headaches and sleepless
nights? Um, do the right thing. You know,
it'd be a person for once, you know,
step back a second. I'm thinking
about it because almost up person,
you might not agree with my positions.
You might not like what I have to say.
You might, you might really this
Walkman, but what you did was wrong.
What you did was like, and you know, it's,
if anything,
hopefully you've learned something that
hopefully you just turned around and
looked in the mirror for a second and
gone that that makes me a bad person.
Like, if that was my idea or if
I'm the editor, whoever it is.
And now also Jim Jefferies, I've
heard people say, um, you know,
excusing in Jeffries, he's not the
one that cuts it. You know what he's,
he's certainly seen the final cut is also,
you know,
had had to do the pieces to camera where
he knew he was throwing me under the
bus. Look at yourself for a second night.
You were sitting there at the log in,
you're my best, my, we did a photo op. Uh,
you would show, you know, and there was,
I walked out of that that day going maybe
this is not going to end up the way I
expected it to.
Maybe you're actually going to be decent.
And when I say decent by
just representing the,
you interviewed the person who blew half
way around the freaking world to be a
part of your little show just represented.
You didn't do that.
So now is your chance to do the right
thing and don't even do it because you're
scared of what's to come.
And I promise you there's a lot to come,
but do it because it is actually your
chance to recognize what you did and there
are millions around the
world who are watching.
If that's your incentive,
then so be it.
But if it makes you actually recognize
an and become a bigger person out of it,
then my job here is done.
Not Bad man. Some somebody
heard that, I guarantee you.
And that's all it takes is a little
spark with some of these people to,
to get the inertia going,
you know?
Well they, you know, they,
they often claim to be,
to work from an emotional place.
I'm speaking to them right now on an
emotional level because, you know,
I'm grateful I caught it. I could not
imagine where I would be emotionally.
Where would I be as a person emotionally
if what was put out was just their
version of the veins. No, well your
career would be over basically.
Not even in my career,
my mental,
I don't think there's anything
worse then, um, you know,
being blamed for something you
didn't do. Um, knowing like,
seeing what they produced
and knowing the truth,
me knowing only may not, I mean not
being able to prove it to anyone.
I couldn't imagine not just, I not
consider myself a pretty strong person,
uh, like mentally strong and I'd
been through a lot in my lab.
I don't know if I would have survived
that and that, you know, they talk about,
they often talk about people,
you know,
pushing people over the edge because
how dare you criticize their religion or
criticize ideas though,
did say something against transgender
or gay marriage because you're going to
ruin people's psychology,
you know?
Yeah.
What were you going to do to me?
What were you going to do
to another human being?
Okay.
How long is it going to take
you to get back into the states?
Did they tell you once you
fill out all this stuff,
the bad visa thing? And I've had a few
great people reach out to me already. Uh,
you know, from, I don't want
to, um, highlighting are,
but people who wield power in the US.
So I don't think it's going to
be too much of an issue and uh,
as Ani would say,
I'll be back.
Um, I think, I think we hit
the main points here. Uh,
hopefully. Yeah, hopefully this does
a little something. I mean, just this,
I will ask you one other thing actually
before we wrap up. So I find that
I, am he just a, anyone knows
anyone are you judging? May Not.
Only for my action will for the way I'm
stringing my sentences together now.
It's 2:00 AM
all right. We got all right.
You got to get to bed.
So I'll just ask you one other thing
then, which is where do you think, uh,
you know,
I know you're not going to view it this
way because I asked this question to a
lot of people and they
never accept the premise,
but where do you think the bravery comes
from within you that you're willing to
fight this?
He could because everyone that I know
that it stood up to the mob has survived
and not only has survived has actually
thrive, thrive yet. When I go out,
when I go out to colleges,
when I do speak in gigs,
the number one thing I get from people
is I'm afraid they're afraid to lose
their job. They're afraid to lose family
members, they afraid to lose friends,
etc. Etc. So, so where do you
think it comes from within you?
Uh, I honestly, I do not. I don't
think of it as bravery running.
Think of it as stupidity. Yep. I'll,
I'll leave you with one story that pretty
much sums it up for me. It actually,
um, it's, it's kind of how I feel every
day. We're not served in the Israeli army.
I was in a, we, we were,
um, we were ambushed.
I had an Arab, it really good
friend of mine, he's an Arab office,
I Christian officer, and
this just described exactly
how I feel every single day.
Um,
and he says,
so we were ambushed from in front and
we were actually leaving the Gaza Strip
from him from,
from about five meters and treated as
a pod terrorists and from behind where
they were in long range artillery
that were firing from two site. Now,
there was about 18,
probably in the class my gun,
and it was an American and for um,
I'm not gonna swear on these shows.
I'm not gonna say
you can swear all you want
it jammed.
So I was basically standing
on the sea on these June,
jumping from side to side, just dodging
bullets. Now at the end of the, uh,
the, the chocolate had come and I thought
that was the game, that night logo.
I don't really believe in God really.
I'm a proud Jew,
but that's a separate story.
That's a whole other show
that not,
I was praying to God.
And then when I heard
that helicopter come in,
the United started firing and finally
things had settled and two of my friends
had been hit. Um, the, I was a marksman.
Now there's two marks means in
every class when you go into combat,
the monument at the front, there's one at
the front and one in the, in the middle.
The management at the front was hit.
So my officer who didn't
know my gun had jammed,
had called me, said Avi, because
you've got to go around to the,
to the bodies to make sure,
because obviously a,
a lot of time they detonate as
you will buy or whatever it is.
So just to make sure the buddies
and that they're actually dead. Um,
and he calls me over and this
is my answer to you as you,
as we're walking around to the body,
it due to the body as I've
said to the officer, um,
the Mike, just so you know, I
have no gun. I had the scopes.
The reason why they take the margin is
because I had the night vision and all
that. I, um, I come Ron and I,
and coming around and it's just
me and him is I said to him,
I have no gun cause what do you
mean you have no gun? I said to him,
my gun is jammed and he's an Arab.
Say he starts cursing me in Arabic and
telling me to get back to the line of
what now, after all that, and
we got out, he tilled today.
Thinks I deserve a medal for that
stupidity and I can't convince him.
I've said to him,
and I'm telling you genuinely,
I have never been more
shit scared in my life.
I think I actually
crapped myself that night,
but he was the aura and it was just not,
the job needs to be done.
And that's what I feel like. Um, you know,
so often now I don't know what I'm
going into. I don't know if, you know,
if you tell me to go back to the days
where I just own gyms and just focused on,
you know, my life, then would I
go back? It's a tough question.
I don't want to think
about it because some days,
some days you're in battles
that you feel are overwhelming,
but if I don't do it,
who will?
I think the moral of the story is everyone
should have an Arab Christian yelling
at them.
Uh, he, he was, he's a legend.
Yes. Listen, I hope,
I hope we've moved the dial
for you a little bit here.
I look forward to getting into the state
so that you can sit in the seat right
across from me and I can shake your hand
and good luck with everything. And A,
and Jeffery's, you're welcome here
too. I'll gladly be a peacemaker.
We got an extra chair,
so let's see if we can do that.
I reckon we should sit together, have a
coffee and talk this one out. Hey Jimmy.
Boy,
we'll have a foresters.
Have a good night. [inaudible] you
been seeing those names, but uh,
I've seen him.
I've seen him yet.
All right.